I do not own my home my children are
unwed we have nothing if this became
known your position in society would
become
untenable my son change does not come
unless you grab it by the
hand King James so struck it's like
a curse give the king whatever he wants
may I perform for you
don't mess up I want you here he will be
yours mine
ours here my l i want you
here I have the power I have the king I
have
England what could possibly stop us now
do be careful now W
water you're a whole dark rude a lot of
you my family is perfect
was that a joke no please
continue who dressed you a prostitute
and lay right down in my
place I had you have on and look even
your flam is off color enjoy the show AR
you done now
[Music]
want now that wide how far will he go
now I want there's nothing you wouldn't
[Music]
do I was raised by a monster only
children believe in
[Music]
Monsters